my name is Elijah and I work at 2 Sigma
um I've been running a team called
quantitative reliability for the last
few years and I'm here to talk about how
we build trust in our data science
pipelines memorize this it's very
important so 2 Sigma we're a
quantitative investment manager said
invest hundreds of thousands of data
sets and dives into them for predictive
power at the center of all of this is
machine learning and statistical
analysis and that's kind of what I'll be
focusing on as I sort of the pipelines
and how that's structured together so on
the agenda today I'll be answering a few
questions first why do we care about
pipelines what's important and how are
they structured next what can go wrong
in a pipeline so what are some edge
cases and where can type lines act
strange how do we improve them so some
best practices that we've learned and
things were implementing and what have
we learned what do we learn from this
experience and what kind of can you take
home the world is full of data you've
got data lakes
that is really fast data reservoirs like
all sorts of water based data metaphors
and and it's it's pervasive in what we
do it's the basis of a lot of what we do
for a living and data in itself however
is not particularly useful unless you're
a data scientist or really good at
crunching the numbers you can't get much
from raw data so in the industry we turn
it into information by using a pipeline
so I'm going to talk a little bit I'm
going to define some terms before we
move on ok so data is just raw facts
collected for reference or analysis so
let's say you're deciding on a city to
move to and you really care about the
weather
some data that might be relevant would
be the highs and lows temperature every
day for the last 10 years that gives you
what you need to know but you have to do
a lot on it before you actually get it
so you may want to actually think about
what information is relevant to you
information is data organized or
present' it to be useful so now that you
have this data what you might actually
want to know is how the temperature
varies on a monthly basis so to turn
that data the daily highs and lows into
information you can aggregate it by
month and take the averages that way you
might know that yours the city you
really like is actually way too hot in
July and way too cold in February and we
do this a lot a lot of this ad hoc
analysis a lot of this turning data into
information so we automate it and that's
called a pipeline which is a software
system that turns data into information
that's what I'll be focusing on this
talk before I talk about actual data
science pipelines I want to tell a story
about another industry something that
represents sort of the challenges and
the concepts fairly well and it's kind
of interesting so let's talk about
camera lenses for a second lenses take
light which is much like data light is
raw it's out there it has everything you
need to know but it's not particularly
organized and turns it into an image
which is much like information it's
distilled and usable by the human eye
lenses have been around for quite a
while one of the more the first modern
lenses was created in 1817 discovered in
1817 by a carl friedrich gauss it's
called the Gauss objective lens and
consists of two closely spaced menisci
they're just pieces of glass a negative
1 and a positive 1 referring to the
concavity are conduc City and this was a
design of a nearly perfect lens so it
had very few aberrations but again it
was nearly perfect and
we can and people continue to improve
upon it so this is where it started this
is a nice simple elegant system very
easy to work with very easy to
understand but it got more complicated
over time so in 1888
Alvin Clark and Bosch and long refined
the design by placing two of these
together
turns out it's better has a different
aperture great we've got a new version
seven years later if it is a more
optimal system in 1896 they added too
thick interior minister again a
different aperture corrected for
chromatic aberrations and shipped this
one and the one most resembling modern
lenses kind of the sort of on the start
of what we see in cameras to this day
was created by Taylor Taylor in Hobson
in 1920 the cool thing about this is
it's asymmetric so it's kind of an
interesting design and ends up creating
a better lens with your aberrations and
the system that started off so simple
got more complicated so which started
off as these two pieces of glass ended
up in hundreds of different designs over
the years forming the basis of a lot of
modern lenses we have in cameras by this
day created by a bunch of different
companies so we've witnessed a system so
it's gone from very simple to complex
and there's nothing inherently bad about
a complex system but there are
challenges you have to navigate so in a
complex system if a piece is broken so
let's say in a complex system you've
gotten it to work perfectly you've
managed to put all the pieces of glass
together such that you get the optimal
image if a piece is broken or for
instance the manufacturer that creates
that material is no longer around to
give you the next very end it might not
work exactly as intended the image might
not look correct it takes a lot of work
get it working again and to make sure
that it's robust to these changes the
system has gone from simple to complex
and furthermore it's difficult to verify
it's hard to know that your lens is
producing the correct image it's
subjective and it's fairly interesting
they have all sorts of strategies in the
camera industry for doing this I'm not
gonna go into them now but if you have
questions I've done some research but I
want to bring this back to data science
pipelines sort of see use this model to
talk about where 2 Sigma was and some of
the problems that we've faced so recall
we're taking up pipeline and replacing a
piece in 2015 we had a fairly
complicated pipeline we run large
collections of back tests for training
simulations this is where we spend the
majority of our compute and most of it
the platform is written in Java so back
at the time I think in 2001 using Java
was fairly bold and we've seen it
through a bunch of different iterations
by this time we ended up at Java 7 and
it came time to upgrade Java 8 has all
sorts of great features
we've got lambda functions and default
functions interface is so he wanted to
replace Java 7 which was pervasive
throughout her system with Java 8 this
was not as easy as you might think like
obviously what can go wrong with a
routine upgrade well it turns out a lot
of things went wrong and I want to talk
about one of the more sort of funky
problems we saw the problem that we
observed was non-determinism so
non-determinism occurs when you take a
program run it record the results take
that program run it again and record the
results with the exact same inputs and
the results end up being different for
no perceived reason and you keep doing
that and get different results that's
crazy that is not how you think these
systems should work
especially if you didn't intend it to be
that way and it caused a lot of
headaches for us it caused us to have
reduced confidence in our processes the
results that weren't reproducible we
couldn't share among the company because
they couldn't actually be recreated and
our trading simulations behaved
erratically worst of all given that we
had so many different results sets we
didn't even know what the right result
was so we started debugging it debugging
this was not easy
we had to contend with a lot of
different things that made it hard so we
had to work with black boxes pieces of
the system that you can't really see
inside you know an adult of knowledge
about pieces that were guarded due to IP
sense of intellectual property
sensitivity or certain people are
experts in and not everybody knew about
and we couldn't just dive into complex
monoliths large systems that shared
state that you can't just start from a
certain point or replay from scratch you
had to build the state up over time and
that made it hard to work with hard to
dive in isolate the problem and debug
finally no single team was responsible
for this whole thing everybody was doing
their job well they were all looking at
their component and ensuring that that
piece got the right results but nobody
was looking at the whole picture at how
Java interacted with his system so we
kept debugging worked our way through
this and after a lot of headaches we
ruled out a few things that usually
caused non-determinism so a standard
topic is race conditions and we found
some race conditions in certain places
but we realized that that wasn't
actually causing this we didn't use
random number generators and if we did
we seeded them which is a pretty
standard strategy to make something a
pure random but actually be
deterministic and it was not gamma rays
we didn't experience this more when we
had solar flares I'm gonna explain what
was happened
after a while after a lot of debugging
so to understand the explanation there
are two topics that I want to kind of
dive into one is floating-point numbers
and why they're weird and the other is
the Java collection spec floating-point
numbers there is a great quote I read
recently somebody said a leaky
abstraction is a black box that you have
to open up on occasion open up
occasionally and I think that's a great
description for why floating point
numbers function so strangely
so floating point numbers are an
abstraction over real numbers but and
you'd expect them as they're an
abstraction to behave all to observe all
the same properties but it turns out
that they actually don't there are
certain cases in which properties such
as associativity which I'll show you in
a second don't behave as you'd think so
this is an example from Python uh it's
fairly simple but it shows how reversing
the order of addition doesn't do exactly
what you might think now we're adding
these three numbers in reverse order in
the first case and getting exactly what
you'd expect and in ascending order in
the second case and getting something
just slightly off that difference is
called an alt ULP that means the
smallest difference between two
floating-point numbers and well it's not
huge it's enough to raise hairs it's
enough to say something's off
let's look at the Java collection spec
the other piece of the puzzle so a
collection you may know in Java holds a
bunch of different objects and the
collection that we're gonna be talking
about here is a map which holds
associations from keys to values
specifically a hash map you can do a lot
of things with a hash map and one of the
more common operations is to it
right through it to run through all the
numbers from the beginning to the end
and get them all in an iterator so some
of you probably see where this is going
but if you don't don't feel bad because
this took us a long time to figure out
between in all versions of Java the
iteration order has never been specified
in the contract so reading the Java doc
you can see that some map
implementations like the tree map class
make specific guarantees as to their
order others like the hashmap class our
culprit here do not between Java 1 and
Java 7 this iteration order happened to
be deterministic you could say iterate
you could iterate through a hash map and
do that exact name again and you were
guaranteed not by contract but by
implementation to get the right result
sure to get the same result in Java 8
something funny happened this iteration
order became non-deterministic so the
reason for this is interesting and
there's a lot of history behind it but
in essence they decided to use a tree to
resolve collisions instead of a linked
list in certain cases so when there are
more than eight collisions which rarely
happens they would use a tree to handle
all of that this is specifically like an
attack mode where you think your hash
map is getting overcrowded and that
would be all good and find a tree should
be deterministic in iteration order as
well unless you're not actually good at
breaking ties and your objects don't
implement comparable fairly well so in
that case in which there is no good
comparable to work off of they use the
system that identity hash code the
system dot identity hash code uses the
location in memory as known by Java to
spit out an identity for a hash value
for an object and that in itself there's
no guarantee from run to run because it
just depends on how Java organizes its
memory so these trees ended up having an
iteration order it could occasionally
depend on the system identity hash code
as the as iterate
through the whole hashmap iterated
through the trees as well that ended up
being non-deterministic in order so to
put this together
we've got hash maps that store key value
data and we perform aggregations over
those values so that require
associativity and the iteration order
actually changes the aggregation results
due to how floating-point numbers are
weird
so the impact on our system was all over
the place
you've got hash map data that's keyed on
stock ID so remember making predictions
on instruments on stocks here algorithms
use this data to make predictions they
run normalizations
they calculate moments they have sun
assign quantiles and run regressions
these are all like the bits and pieces
that make up your machine learning
algorithm and the when you string these
together these little bits these alts
end up magnifying so especially when you
put them together with a whole pipeline
that ends up having a very big impact
and as financial company we really care
now that impact and our models were
producing non-deterministic output the
solution here isn't particularly
profound but you want to be able to use
mapping structures if you're doing
aggregations that guarantee the order
such as linked hash map and tree map and
you don't want to rely on the
implementation details it's worth
reading the contract reading the fine
print to figure out exactly what will
happen but these won't actually solve
every problem we saw another non
determinism issue it was really weird
and this is kind of a fun one to talk
about so we some more non determinism
when we upgraded Java 8 specifically a
minor Java 8 upgrade from one version to
another and ok so we can mine our Java 8
upgrade and after some digging around we
realized that the culprit was a function
Pawel mascot pal raises the number x2
another number why and it was producing
results that were non-deterministic this
is not supposed to happen it's actually
very unclear whether it's in the
contract or not but it's kind of the
contract that people assume when they
sit down to write programs so after
creating a reproduction and banging our
head against the wall we did what all
reasonable engineers would do which is
open up a ticket to the Java to the
people who'd written this saying this
thing is broken and the result we got
was interesting it turns out that math
dot Powell where specifically where the
number the exponent was to contain an
optimization bug so to understand this
an optimization bug meaning a compiler
optimization bug so to understand why
this occurs you have to know what the
just-in-time compiler is which is a tool
that compiles code as your program is
being executed it's running a lot of
it's used heavily throughout Java and it
can do some really cool things so it can
kind of do adaptive learning on the
branches in your program to figure out
like which one is faster and where it
wants to go and in this case it was
making a choice between two different
paths x times x and x squared
now again you these are the same right
like mathematically these are equivalent
expressions but for floating-point
numbers these actually aren't the
implementations of these functions in
math utilizes different pieces different
machine code actually so it would
non-deterministically do to a bunch of
different heuristics choose between
these two values and they would get
different results leading to different
results in our code so the explanation
is here you can see the machine code
instructions I think there are two
different systems but in one case it was
using F mul they're pretty standard
multiplier and the other case
he's using mol SD or V mol SD which I
think are more precise multipliers for
certain types of floating points so
these problems kind of plagued us we
were curious where to go from here we
realized we couldn't just keep playing
whack-a-mole and we needed to be a
little more proactive about it we needed
eyes over a pipeline and we needed
somebody who could see the forest for
the trees so we created a team and we
called it quantitative reliability
that's where I come in I'm gonna spend
the rest of the talk telling you first
about how we think about these types of
problems and what our role is and then
next about some of the specific problems
we've faced and how we approach them so
the goal of this team is to evaluate
quality of quantitative results recall
that light camera lenses they're nuanced
and are hard to judge so this is quite a
piece of work so starting off I'd always
thought of software systems as kind of
being working or not working being a
binary so they were up or they were down
they you're metric was green or red your
system was working or not online or
offline and your tests were passing or
failing this kind of framework and way
of thinking had always appealed to me
but it turns out as we started there's
kind of more of a spectrum here so your
quantitative results can aim can start
off as utter garbage can be on one hand
utter garbage garbage in garbage out and
the other hand for high-quality handling
edge cases and building a nice cohesive
picture of the world so at the first at
the start we started trying to make this
more perfect getting each result to be
cleaner but that was only one piece of
the picture one piece of the puzzle it
turns out that we actually had there was
a cost to making every result better so
not only did we have to consider result
quality but we also had to think about a
trade-off in some sort of cost
so this cost could be any number of
things there's the time we save so by
the way this axis is kind of funny the
high cost is at the bottom you can think
this is inexpensiveness and the low cost
is at the top there it's about that in
mind anything by the time we've saved
the actual cost of data we get of code
we write of systems we use the compute
resources we use sometimes you can for
instance if you run a machine learning
program for more iterations you can
actually get a better result but it's
not always clear that it's worth it and
the operational burden so it takes a lot
of people a lot of hard work to make
results good so to understand how to
make this trade-off I'm going to borrow
a concept from finance we are a finance
company after all called the efficient
frontier this is a concept that's used
in portfolio optimization so portfolio
optimization of the science where you
decide how to construct a portfolio you
have a set of stocks and you want to
figure out what's the optimal portfolio
of these stocks
to do so you have a few things to
consider one is the expected returns
from these stocks and the other is the
risk associated with it so expected
returns is how well you think it'll do
how much money do you think I'll make
from that stock and the risk is what's
the variance on that what are the error
bars it turns out there's actually an
inherent trade-off between these two and
there's no one best portfolio solution
there are a lot of them in fact they fit
along a curve that looks kind of like
this to bring this back to - looking at
our result quality when you think about
the result quality kind of as the
returns how well do you want to do and
these costs as the risk so let's look at
a few points on this if you're on the
upper left of this you can have
inexpensive low-quality results so you
run some sort of cheap algorithm that
approximate it's it but it doesn't take
a lot of work and doesn't do very well
or you can have expensive
high-quality results these are both good
places to be you're on the curve you're
doing as well as possible however where
you don't want to be is here you don't
want to have suboptimal results you
don't want to be within this curve
because that means that for the same
result quality you're getting you could
spend less time you could spend less
money or for the same cost you get a
better result so the goal of this team
is to push things out to the frontier
and make sure we're functioning
optimally so when we approach these
problems we've got a few different hats
to wear we're a team of many hats and
these are really just sort of way scopes
at which we think about these problems
looking at the actual data sort of
functioning as a data scientist we've
got the data detective this is people
like the way of thinking that's solving
that non-determinism problem really
digging in and really figuring out what
the actual issue is so taking us from
behaving within the curve to on the
frontier of the curve the engineer
builds out frameworks addresses those
issues on a more systemic level and make
sure that we're continually behaving
optimally so the engineer might be
building out frameworks to test for
determinism or pushing forward with a
java upgrade and that's a high scope is
the architect designing the system
figuring out what that curve looks like
and how we should actually be
functioning not just where we are or we
could be using this framework I'm going
to be talking a bit about some of the
problems we've seen with a through a
specific example and this example is
that of aggregate pulling models which I
find very interesting am fairly relevant
to this day so an aggregate pulling
model the goal is to predict election
results based off of polls so up
poll is where you we're a company that
often specializes in this calls up
people and ask them their opinion it
could be they could call them they could
email them there could be a survey sent
out and specifically about political
elections so from the one you probably
know that does the team you probably
know that does the best job of this is
called 538 they think we're stood within
New York Times back in the day but Nate
silver a fairly well known data
scientist run this and this is their
most recent forecast or one of their
more recent forecasts for the
congressional elections in 2018 this is
a really complicated system and there's
all sorts of great blogs about how they
create this but the things to note are
that it outputs something fairly
complicated a probability distribution
so it doesn't just say this will happen
but it says here are a range of results
as to what may happen and I'm not gonna
go into detail as to how theirs works
but let's look at a simplified version
of how one might construct an IRA get
pulling model so you've got the data
coming in your historical polling data
that is the result of polls going back
in time from this you construct weighted
averages you want to get a probability
for each one of these congressional
districts so you use each historical
polling data each historical polling
datum to get that average then as you
cannot really come up with a closed-form
probability distribution for this you
run a Monte Carlo simulation which is
just sample from a probability
distribution and see what happens
and finally the Monte Carlo simulation
outputs a probability distribution
remember the Monte Carlo simulations use
some amount of randomness in this so you
get a fairly interesting output so a
problem that you might observe that
we've seen is that of stateful models so
the assumption here and you may not
agree with this but again it's a
trade-off is it models should behave
like perfect functions from the same
exact input they should get
the same exact output and so this often
occurs in time series model where you
primed them you run them for certain
amounts of time and the results may
differ based on the start time of it so
you want to know the forecast the day
before the election because that's the
most important but if you run that model
warm it up on six months of data versus
running it on twelve months of data you
could actually get different results now
again this is a trade-off you may really
care about this is maybe very important
to your system or it might not be for us
it is so I'm going to talk about how
this might occur and some best practices
this happens when models carry internal
state so by internal state in this case
here's what I mean remember this part of
the pipeline your machine learning
models taken historical polling data and
they construct weighted averages the
weighted averages are built using two
sort of pieces of information one is
some sort of subjective weighting on the
quality of that poll some pollsters are
more reliable than others and the other
is the recency so if you've know if you
know the term exponential moving average
that's a common implementation of some
sort of weighting based off of recency
and what's happening is that your model
is remembering the data that it's seen
so it's running through this collecting
each pole and adding that to its
internal internal state the average this
causes it to be stateful because it
really just has more data when it's
running for twelve months than six
months now
the solution to this is kind of to
slightly adjust how we think about it
and write stateless models by stateless
models I don't mean that it can't take
in a lot of data your model should
absolute can absolutely be taking in a
lot of data but you want it to be taking
in all this data as input and not as a
side effect so if instead of taking in
just that day's data each day you run it
your model takes in a history of data
perhaps a fixed history of the last six
months
or a infinite history then everyday
it'll have all the previous data that
needs having conduct you can construct a
weighted average it's the first approach
kind of what the data detective might
take making sure that we function more
optimally and have systems that are more
less stateful and the higher scope
approaches actually build a framework to
test for State so when you release a new
weighting system and you model you can
actually test it to make sure that it
gets the same results for six months and
twelve months beforehand let's talk
about the problem of validating your
pipeline so the symptom here is kind of
vague pipelines produce unexpected
results for instance as an example the
election results are skewed towards one
outcome you expect to see distributions
like this nice and normal
like all data is normal but instead
you're seeing something funky like this
where it's all focused on one specific
piece the explanation of these types of
issues can kind of be anywhere
and the data you see and the code you've
written to do this in the framework that
you use and rely upon or the
infrastructure that you use to get the
data into your code but the thing I'm
kind of referring to is when you use a
hard-coded random seed in your Monte
Carlo sim so you probably so let's say
this model took the lesson about non
determinism to heart I wanted to make
systems super reproducible you have to
have the right set of random seeds so
the Monte Carlo simulation gets
reasonable results so again this is a
sort of smaller scope to answer this
solves the specific problem but in
general we want to think about again
about our systems as a function so it's
good to define a contract and validate
it regularly so a contract in this case
might be that the results of your
pipeline are normally distributed with a
certain standard range of standard
deviations and a range of means and you
could run that regularly to make sure
that your system is working every time
you release new data you ensure that
it's still getting standardly normal
distributed standard normal
tribution x' I put it this takes a lot
of work and again it's a trade off it's
not always worth it but and it requires
a lot of knowledge about how your system
works but we found this to be very
valuable and it's helped us cut a lot
catch a lot of interesting bugs so the
last forum I want to talk about is input
data sensitivity so the symptom is that
your models are susceptible to slight
changes in input let's take an example
if you add a new set of similar poles so
let's say you have one set of poles from
one pollster and you have another
pollster that kind of tracks that
pollster fairly closely so you add in
their poles as well for doing more data
the better but you don't expect the
results to change that much and it turns
out on occasions it results you don't
expect to change do the explanation here
is often due to unstable numeric
algorithms so algorithms that really
react to this there are a lot of these
k-means clustering ends up being very
sensitive to outliers when you have
algorithms that divide by Z score you
can suffer from actual floating-point
things that have huge sort of cascading
effects but the best practices here are
to actually run sensitivity tests by
perturbing your input data so this is a
pretty standard strategy and we've
gotten some mileage out of it but you
could add little fuzz to your poles to
make sure the results don't actually
change that much add that to your
contract so we define and run it
regularly to make sure your system stays
stable and shuffle your input data to
test your models robustness so ensure
that so this is a very common strategy
in machine learning but to make sure
you're not overfitting to the order you
see you can change around the input data
it's a very easy thing to do and it
works in non time series models or
models very well because the order
really canst not matter and if your
results are crazy and are very different
based on the shuffling then you probably
have some sort of instability in the
system so to get started with
quantitative reliability first it's
worth labeling problems as quantitative
reliability think about you
probably seen a lot of things like this
and we're thinking about them as
problems that aren't just simple that
you can't just fix like a bug but that
have sort of more complicated solutions
on our part of trade-offs and nuanced
results then start off small dedicated
quantitative reliability engineer who
can sort of look at the bigger picture
and and you mean look it's a bigger
picture and see the forest for the trees
you can really like focus in on the
details function as the data detective
but also start building out frameworks
and thinking about the whole system and
work with people across the company then
expand in scope so you'll start off
doing work as a data detective figuring
out a bunch of issues and getting sort
of a track record up then you'll start
building systems to address those issues
and classes of issues and then you'll
start designing the next system so you
don't see those issues in the future
and oh there are a lot of other problems
that I haven't hit on did I think would
be valuable to look at in this space or
that would I would think would fall
under the umbrella of quantitative
reliability so for instance
understanding your machine learning
pipelines there's a great talk last year
about diving into the black box and
that's a hot topic and I think that
falls under quantitative reliability is
to trade-off between the result quality
and sort of how you understand it and
the actual cost of digging in and trying
to understand that versus producing new
models
there's selecting hardware which can
have really interesting impacts on
quantitative results testing your
machine learning algorithms for going
out how to validate them so they do well
there's a talk right after this one and
I think the next building in which they
proposed a framework to do just that
ensuring reproducible research again
it's a trade-off between the work you
put in and the results you get and how
usable they are in the future and just
validating your data we get data in from
everywhere and making sure that it's
sane is quite a bit of work that can
really impact your result quality so
back to the questions that I asked at
the beginning why do we care about
pipelines
well pipelines turn data into usable
information
most companies have some sort of data
pipelines that impact how they function
and help them make business decisions
what can go wrong in a pipeline well
everything can go wrong in a pipeline
pipelines grow in complexity and have a
lot of moving pieces Island a bunch of
possible issues and there are a lot more
how do we improve them well here are
some best practices writing stateless
systems defining and validating your
contracts run input sensitivity tests
and just validate your models as a
function so if you test attributes
that's the state statelessness
determinism and quantitative robustness
and finally what have we learned
well pipelines are too complex to manage
themselves think about quantitative
reliability and consider actually making
a team or really focusing in on these
thank you so much
and have a lovely evening I'm happy to
answer questions or just like hang
around after the talk
[Applause]